bonjour a tous déjà ils viennent
présenter son nouveau mari caire un
nouveau drone qui peut être très
intéressant et pour pas mal de points ça
justement on va en parler
[Musique]
dj est une marque que vous connaissez
forcément parce que dj am c'est vrai que
c'est le roi du drone le roi du drone
grand public
alors il ya aussi des produits dédiés
pour les professionnels mais c'est vrai
que pour grand public dj hi est hyper
connue il ya eu le fantôme trois tomes 4
phantom quatre pros le magic prom avec
pro platinum
il ya l'osm aux os mobile os mobile de
l'osm au plus failli à une gamme qui est
hyper large chez dj hype il ya aussi une
gamme plus professionnel mais c'est vrai
que pour le grand public
dj hi est hyper présent ils ont sorti
l'année dernière le spark
c'est un drône hyper compact très facile
à piloter qui l'a s'adresse énormément
au grand public et effectivement mais
d'annoncer un nouveau drone qui
s'appelle le mât vicaire qui est en gros
à mi chemin mais les grandes guillemets
entre le mavic pro mavic pro platinum
sont deux produits dans la gamme mavic
et de l'autre côté le spark parce que
c'est vrai que cela vicaire ressemble
énormément sparte
mais il a toutes les qualités du magic
pro et à un tarif beaucoup plus bas on
va regarder ce qu'est ce nouveau
medicare à qui s'adresse qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire avec qu'elle est un peu la
différence par rapport aux mac pro est
est ce que ça vaut le coup de l'acheter
au ring
le mât vicaire coupe avec la ligue pro
il est plus petit nous fait vraiment
penser à ce parc
effectivement beaucoup plus compact il
se range très facilement un peu dans
l'esprit du magic pro on n'a pas changé
on n'est pas sur l'idée du design des
fantômes 4 ou des fantômes 3 on est
vraiment quelque chose de très compact
il est deux fois plus petit que le magic
pro et 41 % plus léger donc là c'est
plutôt pas mal
le poc a vraiment été mis en avant par
dj house et la portabilité c'est
vraiment un drôle que vous pouvez
emmener partout avec vous ils ont fait
la démo il avait dans sa poche la
télécommande dans l'autre encore avec un
autre drone fin on va vraiment que c'est
un produit qu'on peut très facilement
emmener avec soi où que vous soyez si
vous êtes créateur de contenu vous le
sortez facilement vous le piloter vous
faites ce que vous voulez c'est le
premier drone avec une si petite taille
qui a un stabilisateur sur trois axes on
peut filmer en cap cas à 30 images par
seconde en 100 mégabits par seconde
si vous voulez filmé en 60 images par
seconde il faut descendre en 2007 qu'à
bagdad pendant un peu bâtard mais on
peut les cendres en 2,7 cas vous pouvez
aussi le faire en full hd et si vous
voulez faire du slow motion
vous descendez en full hd peut filmer
jusqu'à 120 images par seconde
c'est plutôt pas mal après effectivement
on regrette on peut regretter quand
quelqu'un on ne peut pas on ne puisse
pas filmer en 60 images par seconde
bon c'est pas très grave c'est vrai que
ça aurait été mieux alors c'est un drone
qui va encore plus loin pour
l'utilisation je dirais semi
professionnel vous avez cette caméra
tout autour du drone qui vont capter
l'environnement qui vont refaire une
espèce de carte en trois dimensions pour
vraiment repérer les reliefs pour
repérer en gros ce que vous avez autour
ce qui fait que lorsque vous allez
piloter votre drones qui va se
rapprocher d'un arbre il va aller vite
et par lui-même il a soit contournée
soit passé au dessus pareil pour tous
les obstacles ce soir au cheikh sow ce
que vous voulez il va effectivement
contrôlé tout seul donc bon on voit
vraiment qu'il ya un vrai assistant de
vol pour d'une préserver les drones et
pour deux l'expérience utilisateur ça va
quand même plus sympa c'est dommage
d'aller planter ce qu'on sait vraiment
quand on commence à piloter un drone les
erreurs sont hyper fréquentes
donc ça c'est assez intéressant et on
voit vraiment qu'on s'adresse aux semi
professionnel voire carrément à
l'amateur qui rentre dans cette gamme de
produits vous pouvez le piloter pendant
vingt et une minutes
vingt-et-une minutes oui mais à 25 km
heure on n'a pas s'affoler si vous êtes
en mode sport qui va jusqu'à 60
kilomètres heure vous allez forcément
voler beaucoup moins parce que vous avez
forcément pour sauver plus voilà très
très logique tout ça
vous pouvez plus et jusqu'à une distance
de 4 km côté photo vidéo vous avez une
caméra de 12 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de 2.8
ça correspond si vous voulez un objectif
de 24 mm pour la netteté ifat minimum à
50 cm et pour la plage iso pour la vidéo
vous aller de 100 à 1600 iso et pour la
vidéo de 100 à 3200 iso en mode manuel
pour la photo pourrait faire de beaux
panoramas ya du hdr en plus qui s'affale
dans ce drôle ça vous pouvez stocker
jusqu'à 8 giga octet à l'intérieur donc
lorsque votre carte est pleine ou vous
avez oublié votre carte vous pouvez
quand même filmé et ça c'est plutôt pas
mal
vous avez un port usb c est pour les
cartes c'est la microsd pour la vidéo
vous avez toute une série de scènes
assez facile vous pouvez faire de
l'actif trac c'est à dire qu'il va vous
suivre il va suivre vos déplacements
vous avez des quizz chocmod qu'ils ont
et des modes de prise de vue facile
en gros si vous voulez c'est des espèces
de près 7 qui sont prêts créé pré
programmés par des gi's vous avez qu à
les lancer et ça fait plein de
mouvements ça fait différent un peu
autour de vous alors vous avez le
brownie vous avez le cercle vous avez
les leaks le rocket et en plus ça ils
ont rajouté l'astéroïde et bouillargues
c'est effectivement le côté automatique
mais ça fait quand même son petit effet
c'est plutôt pas mal comme sur le spark
vous avez la reconnaissance des gestes
vous pouvez le démarrer directement le
thé cov décollage avec votre main vous
le piloter les mouvements sont très
précis ça leur connaît très bien il ya
une démo ça a l'air d'être en tout cas
vraiment pas mal g saint gall ce parc
c'est vrai que je dois reconnaître que
c'est un produit qui est assez bluffant
ce système de pilotage avec la main
c'est très clairement adressés je dirais
plutôt à l'amateur à des personnes qui
veulent se faire plaisir tokotoko
professionnel très clairement voilà
après si vous voulez en france à côté un
peu plus pro vous avez une télécommande
dans la télécommande ce qui en plus
super intéressant c'est qu'elle est
vraiment fait pour pouvoir être emmener
partout avec vous vous avez les petits
boutons joystick vous les démonter
voulait ranger dans vous la prenez vous
la mettez dans la poche c'est vraiment
un produit qui fait pour être emmener
partout avec soi et qui est un maximum
de flexibilité
le mât vicaire et plus rapide que le
magic pro il peut aller jusqu'à 68 4 km
heure en mode sport et 28,8 km/heure en
mode wifi il est résistant au vent sur
des bourrasques bourrasques de 29 à 38
km heure si effectivement il ya beaucoup
de vent là vous étiez de le sortir parce
que votre drones
ça va vous le coucher il est disponible
en trois couleurs arctic white onyx
black et le flame red bon il est blanc
noir rouge
voilà pour faire simple c'est un produit
qui est vendue au tarif de 849 euros
le mavic pro lui fait 1199 euros et le
magic pro platinum fait 1299 euros
et si vous regardez le cri du spark
aujourd'hui il est à 499 euros au lieu
de 599 euros normalement sur le site de
dj hi
donc on a vraiment qu'on est sur un
produit qui se positionne à mi chemin on
voit que c'est un peu le produit
manquant dans la gamme dj hi
parce que si vous aimez ce type de
produit compact emmener partout parce
que là on parle pas du tout nouveau tome
4 phantom 4 vous n'allez pas l'emmener
partout
ces deux produits font la malle est
mince et le plus contraignant le produit
vous pouvez emmener partout avec vous
c'est effectivement le spark est
maintenant le mât vicaire mais les pros
c'est pareil il est un petit peu plus
gros donc le na'vi caire voyez bien que
on est vraiment dans cette gamme de
produits dans l'antre 2 dj hi va cherche
effectivement à toucher un public qui
n'a pas forcément avec son indic pro on
est en dessous des 1000 euro symbolique
on est effectivement pas sur le produit
le moins cher mais voilà on est vraiment
sur l'antre 2 on va très bien que déjà
il va chercher à séduire un nouveau
public à rendre le groupe toujours plus
facile d'accès donc voilà c'est très
clairement une stratégie un nouveau
produit l'année dernière il ya une mise
à jour du macbook pro et dans les rios 6
le spark
donc on va encore que la gamme s'élargit
et c'est super intéressant d'autant plus
le dj avait assorti il n'ya pas
longtemps
l'os mobile 2 que j'ai pu tester
d'ailleurs si vous allez voir la vidéo
est ici donc on voit qu'effectivement
ils vont aller toujours plus loin sur
des produits un peu moins cher pour
s'adapter aussi à la concurrence et aux
besoins du public
[Musique]
alors la grosse différence par rapport
aux navires pro rien a forcément déjà
voulait le format est ce que c'est un
produit qui va être un peu différent qui
va réagir un peu différemment en vol
donc le jour où je les sers et je vous
en dirai davantage sur ce point là en
tout cas sur le papier il ya l'air
d'être quand même plutôt séduisant il ya
un temps de vol qui est différent le
navigue prompt volera plus longtemps
wade complète indom vol 30 minutes le
mavic pro 27 minutes et lui
vingt-et-une minutes côté vidéo dans
tous les cas vous filmer en 4k 30 images
par seconde donc bon voilà il n'y a pas
non plus un écart énorme
c'est un produit qui est séduisant qui a
vraiment l'avantagé d'être en dessous
des 1000 euros et qui comme je vous le
dis s'adresse vraiment un public de
créateurs de contenu vidéo en ligne que
ce soit sur youtube sur facebook ou sur
les réseaux qui vont venir à l'avenir
parce qu'il va y en avoir sera continué
à se développer toute façon les vues
aériennes quelque chose qui va
énormément développés et par rapport à
ça il ya aussi toute une législation
voilà il faut il faut faire attention
aussi à ce sujet je vous invite dès
évidemment à vous renseigner sur la
législation pour pas faire voler votre
drones n'importe où si ce drone vous
intéresser si vous êtes curieux je vous
ai mis un lien dans la description pour
en savoir plus
en tout cas sur papier je trouve plutôt
pas mal et puis effectivement il
al'avantage de rendre les gammes mavic
plus accessible dites moi vous ce que
vous en pensez à ce que vous pourriez
vous laisser tenter
est-ce que vous avez un mac pro est ce
que vous avez un fantôme 4 est-ce que
vous avez un ce parc est ce que cela
vicaire pourrait vous intéresser
est ce que vous pensez effectivement
comme moi que c'est un chaînon manquant
dans la gamme de dj hi
et est ce que vous trouvez intéressant
mark et moi tout ça en commentait on en
rediscute ensemble comme d'habitude vous
invite à laisser des jolies pousse à
vous abonner
on reste connectés parce qu'on va parler
toujours plus de high tech j'ai plein de
nouveautés j'ai plein de soucoupes est
en train de vous préparer plein de
surprises donc restez connectés abonnez
vous je vous dis à bientôt
d'ici là soyez sages comme d'habitude
vous enverra les aujourd'hui
aussi gros bisous à bientôt
n'oubliez pas vous êtes les meilleurs et
surtout prenez soin de vous jacques
[Musique]